meine lieben freunde ich darf euch heute
rechte hat sie willkommen heißen seine
neue episode ein neuer tag startet auf
unserer wunderschönen einsamen kleinen
insel auf der leider seit der letzten
folge die kuh nicht mehr unter uns weilt
wegen habe ich mir direkt für den beginn
der heutigen episode etwas gedacht was
ich auf jeden fall der kuh zu liebe
machen möchte und zwar in kleinen
grabstein
ich weiß die kuh war nicht lange unter
uns dieses projekt geht erst zwei folgen
allerdings ist es für mich einfach
wichtig dass wir die kuh vernünftig
verabschieden von daher habe ich mich
ein bisschen of stream
das ist gar kein stream ich habe mir auf
jeden fall eine kleinigkeit überlegt
guten morgen schildkröten danke zunächst
einmal benötigen wir grobe erde dafür
die bruchstein treppen habe ich gerade
schon gemacht und jetzt brauchen wir
noch ein schild will es eigentlich an
einem schönen ort haben allerdings will
ich es auch nicht so komplett im weg rum
stehen oder wir machen es halt auf der
anderen insel das wäre aber ein bisschen
respektlos glaube ich von daher will ich
das grab glaube ich einfach mal hierhin
machen
dafür mache jetzt einfach so und so denn
das hier ist grobe erde und die wird
nicht zu gras das heißt sie bleibt so
und das soll so ein bisschen das grab
darstellen ich habe sogar noch eine
bessere idee wir machen einfach jetzt
noch hier zwei kisten um das ganze jetzt
so ri die traurig zu machen und nehmen
diese kisten und packen die quasi unter
diese grobe erde nämlich genau hier und
hier hin und da packen wir jetzt einfach
das rohr rindfleisch kraft
[Musik]
das ist dass ich einfach aus versehen
die kugel töten darf in der letzten
folge also falls die letzte folge nicht
gesehen haben solltet ihr euch auf jeden
fall gern an
ich habe nämlich dort am ende die crew
aus versehen geschlagen und habe ich das
hier von ihr bekommen ich dachte es wäre
das skelett gewesen was sie abgeschossen
hat allerdings weiche sand oder er tut
mir das auf jeden fall krass leid ich
würde jetzt hier einfach mal so die
sachen hinsetzen ich hab mir da so eine
kleinigkeit überlegt wie man das machen
kann oben auch noch mal so einen dingen
drauf jetzt packen wir hier ein schild
in haikou genau haben wir jetzt so und
hier die erde wieder ab und das hier ist
jetzt quasi das grab für die kuh mit ein
paar blumen und so wäre es auf jeden
fall schöner die haben da hinten die
hollager feuerwehr generell haben wir
viele geschrieben halo kg doch mal rüber
zu den anderen inseln und so weiter und
so fort die sache ist ja möchte ich auch
habe ich richtig bock darauf allerdings
nicht jetzt schon so früh im projekt
also ich will wirklich erstmal hier die
eigene insel bei uns ein bisschen
entdecken und was mir auch wieder gesagt
haben ist luca damit du nicht immer auf
der laser dugard den fortschritten
metall nur metall metall luca du musst
dir unbedingt eine schere machen und
einfach mal das schafscheren ich weiß
nicht ob ich hier von einer kuppel
bekommen nur zwei es mir auch ganz viele
geschrieben hatten da wollte ich mich
unter anderem bei der lieben isabella
bedanken die das geschrieben hat in der
letzten folge
wenn man hier untertaucht kann man
einfach und das wusste nicht weil ich
manchmal verlangen mehr gespielt haben
dass hier abbauen und dann wenn wieder
mal nach oben schwimmen sehen wir haben
seetang und seetang kann man beraten und
dann essen
das heißt wir brauchen theoretisch
wirklich gar keine farben so richtig da
unten denn wir haben wirklich so viel
wasser und soviel seetang hier in
unserer ganzen welt dass wir das einfach
essen können ist der absolute wahnsinn
dann kommen wir der heutigen folge auch
endlich mal zu den namen von dem schaf
commerce frist mir hier wirklich alles
weg namen für die q cells scheißegal
dieser leider höhe gestorben allerdings
wird das schaf schorn heißen
ja aber jedes schaf heißt schon von
daher ist eigentlich ganz okay pepper
und schaden weshalb der absolute
wahnsinn ist es einfach das ist schon
nacht wird das geil dass ihre beute
bekommen koma wie süß schon aussieht
ohne fell ja okay ist es wolle die zeit
bis die sonne untergegangen ist muss ich
jetzt einfach mal für ja nicht für das
aber dass auch in guter gedanke dann
habe ich auch keine bücher gratis
ich hoffe nur dass jetzt keine monster
kommen denn es hat einfach geklappt das
hätte ich nicht gedacht sprechen sie die
ganzen fackeln die wir hier auf unserer
insel gesetzt haben nun leider auch
ziemlich nutzlos
ich hab die halt im ersten schritt die
erst mal hingesetzt weil ich dachte dass
wir noch ein schaf haben und
dementsprechend ja nicht genügend wolle
kriegen wenn man ein schaf tötet was ich
machen würde würde man nur eine rolle
bekommen ich hab gar nicht mehr die
schere gedacht also danke danke danke
euch da auch für die ganz ganz ganz ganz
vielen kommentare wirklich unter diesem
projekt ihr helft mir wirklich extrem
weiter ich war halt lange nicht mehr so
richtig drin in minecraft und haben es
verlernt was hier sache ist deswegen
wenn ihr weiterhin tipps habt schreibt
sie mir gerne und wir setzen uns jetzt
und bisschen an die insel arbeiten hier
wir haben ja ganz ganz viele creeper
löcher ja irgendwie ziemlich häufig
explodiert sind ich weiß jetzt von
meiner unfähigkeit lag oder dass der
schwierigkeitsgrad hier auf normal ist
und nicht auf leicht ich bin ja nicht so
der allerbeste gamer einige aber auch
geschrieben luca bau doch einfach eine
schicht erde darüber dann hast du halt
ein paar löcher aber nie bei mir ist es
irgendwie so ich weiß nicht ich muss
wissen dass es auch
darunter schön aussieht so dumm das
klingt wenn ich irgendeine schublade
habe ich meist auch nicht die t shirts
reinen nur weil ich die nicht sondern
ich will für meinen monk gewissen auch
wissen dass es da drinnen schön ist so
dumm dass gerade klingt scheiße es jetzt
sind wir gerade in der höhle
ich habe eigentlich nicht so bock darauf
jetzt in der höhle hier irgendwie wieder
was mit zombies zu tun zu haben
aber zu reisen sage ich wirklich nie
nein
und da müssen wir auf jeden fall hin
oder unten jetzt auch schon weiter sehe
ich wir können hier einmal ganz kurzen
blick hineinwerfen dass er so ein
bisschen anders war es viele aber auch
geschrieben werden schlug dagegen was in
die richtung luca andere machen so
minecraft plate ruhe und challenges so
hey wie schnell kann man minecraft
durchspielen 15 minuten haben da
irgendwie andere leute geschafft ja aber
das ist nicht mein ziel mein ziel ist
dass er dieses projekt hier zu machen
weil ich einfach merke dass mir
minecraft spaß macht und ich will nicht
dass es jetzt so eine sache wird von
wegen hey ich hab das jetzt in einem tag
durchgespielt und dann ist es halt
vorbei
ich möchte wirklich das ganze projekt
mit ruhe angehen mit bedacht angehen und
habe lust drauf und wenn es euch zu
langsam ist dann zwingt euch keiner
hierzu zugucken wenn ihr da bock drauf
habe dann freut mich das natürlich
allerdings wisst ihr glaube ich was ich
meine so dass hier möchte ich jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal ein bisschen zu bauen
weil das eines der ersten creeper löcher
war die wir in der ersten folge leider
mein gott ich trag jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen erde ab die ich dann nachher
vorne drauf setzen kann
ich weiß ich habe selber gesagt es macht
für mich mehr sinn das wirklich richtig
meine chance schon wieder schrott
schauen was sagst du dazu
das ist doch
ziegelbau folge heute aber wir haben
wirklich schon einiges geschafft ich
habe mich sehr gut informiert sehr doll
gelesen was die letzten kommentare
angehen lassen dass das essen das ja ich
habe es lange nicht gespielt machen wir
so dass gerade das sieht auch ganz schön
was machen wir hier an die seitenwahl
die fackeln dran so da eine machen wir
da hinten noch eine und hier komme ich
mache von der au doch treppen zum glück
lasse ich mich überhaupt nicht ablenken
bei diesem projekt zack zack und sagt
dann haben wir hier vorne wirklich doch
das sieht schön aus ich will das hier
alles so ein bisschen schöner machen die
komplette insel also den strand so ein
bisschen abgesenkt da machen vor allem
auch die triberger zu machen und das
heute ist wirklich so eine richtige
minecraft folge als wir meinen heute
wirklich krass rum
ich baue das ja auch einfach mal ab den
bambus oder zuckerrohr oder wie auch
immer das heißt daraus geht ja woher
soll ich das denn wissen generell haben
wir extrem viele projekte in diesem
projekt also ich möchte ja auch noch das
habe ich auch schon angekündigt die
anderen kommen hier ich mache den
kleinen sandstrand kannst du bist schön
gefällt's dir perfekt gemacht manchmal
wieder so spaß ich weiß nicht wo
[Musik]
wie kann es denn sein dass diese tiere
überall dahin gehen wo ich auch hingehe
usa scharf das sieht schon schön aus mit
dem ding welcher minute sind 23 mich
würde interessieren wie ihr dass die
bist du da rausgekommen
schreibt mir gerne und in die kommentare
wie das am nil der heutigen episode zum
beispiel findet das macht nämlich jetzt
einen 3d designer den ich auf twitter
gefunden habe für mich und mega mega
geil also ich finds richtig schön auch
wenn die nächsten ist dann auch im 3d
look sind generell verliebe ich mich
immer mehr dieses projekt also es läuft
genauso wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe
klar am schönsten wäre es wenn jedes
video 70 millionen aufrufe hätte aber
das bin ich ja auch bin ich ganz ehrlich
und genau das habe ich auch schon im
podcast mit sandra letztens darüber
geredet dass ich einfach immer mehr
merken alles was irgendwie als ziel
gesetzt habe damals oder früher generell
das habe ich erreicht und für mich ist
es aktuell einfach nur noch wichtig dass
das was ich täglich mache dass das mir
einfach spaß bereitet und das ist auch
immer das was ich den leuten gesagt habe
die mich gefragt haben hey was sind
deine tipps für leute die neu mit
youtube anfangen einfach nur spaß daran
haben oder generell wenn man einen neuen
beruf anfängt oder warum
du kommst jetzt bitte hier ganz langsam
zu mir rüber gelaufen
das ist so ein arschloch nicht bei dem
extra nen weg was denn egal ich mache
ich muss hier arbeiten ja du nervst bis
jetzt soll er mich ja anrempeln oder war
es alter und jetzt plötzlich nutzt weg
komplett weg du kommst jetzt nicht
wieder zurückgelaufen du bist doch so
ein arschloch was ich vorhin sagen
wollte war dass ich eigentlich alles das
was ich mir früher mal als ziel gesetzt
habe dass ich das erreicht habe und für
mich ist es aktuell nur noch wichtig
dass das was ich mache mir wirklich spaß
bereitet und das ist jetzt erstmal mit
einer schaufel zu holen hier vorne
brauche ich jetzt auch mal die blöcke ab
ich weiß nicht warum die da immer noch
alle hier eine luft herum schweben
allerdings müssen wir das ja auch mal zu
bauen und dann sieht schon mal deutlich
schöner aus
[Musik]
da also das hat mir schon gut
hingekriegt
klar sieht ein bisschen zu jetzt gebaut
aus mäßig da muss man vielleicht ein
bisschen irgendwie okay das ist es auch
ein bisschen blödsinn so doch ich mich
tragen dabei wenn das gras drauf tags
und so weiter und so fort und alles auch
noch ein bisschen hier drumherum mit dem
strand und sonne kleinigkeiten alles
ausgebessert ist dann könnte schon ganz
schön aus dem glaube ich und da gehe ich
jetzt schlafen werde dann gleich wenn
ich wach bin mir noch einmal schnell
seetang holen dass ich in der nächsten
folge nicht komplett wieder extrem
hungrig bin dementsprechend gehen wir
noch einmal schnell unter wasser wir
können eigentlich noch mal auf unsere
andere insel gehen da war ja auch noch
eine höhle darunter aber das kriegen wir
schon immer da unten sind auch noch
fische die kammer theoretisch auch mal
töten
packen wir hier eben den seetang rein
und das reisen können wir dann nutzen um
uns auch noch mal eben schnell eine neue
spitzhacke zu machen die es mich gerade
kaputt gegangen bei der teil wo ich da
unten alles ein bisschen neu gebaut habe
nachts können uns auch mal aus eisen
machen
das nächste reise nehmen dann auf jeden
fall für rüstungen et cetera das
knochenmehl nehme ich einfach mal und
noch mal nachts nach unten zu unserer
kleinen farm nicht mal die haben ja die
können wir und top benutzen mit unserem
brot und so weiter und so fort hier an
denen das ist schon fertig das ist noch
nicht fertig zack zack zack zack zack
dann können wir das sind nämlich ernten
können uns auch schon mal ein bisschen
brot machen menschen wie macht das spaß
dieses projekt das ist unfassbar dass
ich auch schon überlegt hatte war dass
wir diese farm hier dies ist natürlich
sehr sporadisch spontan jenigen die
hingesetzt worden von mir dass wir die
unterirdisch machen dort was ich gerade
nämlich in der times zu gebaut habe hier
das komplette häuschen will ich auch
noch so ein bisschen schöner bauen
selbstverständlich
damit wir uns ja auch ein bisschen
wohler drin fühlen vielleicht so ein
kleines baumhaus oder so der baum hier
bleibt auf jeden fall stehen richtig an
der stelle wird die heutige episode
minecraft mit lukas allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen lassen einen daumen hoch
unter dem video er da schreibt mir
weiterhin tipps und tricks und in die
kommentare und auch dinge die ich in den
nächsten folgen eurer meinung nach
unbedingt noch umsetzen muss und
abonniert main kanal wenn ihr das dann
nicht verpassen wollte denn übermorgen
um 20 uhr kommt wieder eine neue folge
von minecraft mit luca
[Musik]